[Música]
vivir en la sombra para protegerse Ese
es el día a día de paras esta bailarina
transgénero es una celebridad local
hace unos meses fue amenazada y encontró
refugio en este apartamento
[Música]
ese es mi trabajo es mi profesión Pero
ahora estoy desempleada sentada en casa
mirando mis propios videos
me siento mal me siento destruida
para su yo de su barrio tras haber
vivido un infierno
la bailarina cayó en Las garras de Una
Pandilla local
cuyo líder es un miembro de un partido
político
Esa es mi casa antes vivía allá él lleva
tres años amenazándome
me fui de mi casa vivo con un amigo
no puedo volver a mi casa por su culpa
Alguien podría arrojarme ácido a la cara
o cortarme el cabello o dispararme las
piernas
él quería que yo fuera su esclava quería
que estuviera disponible cuando él
quisiera tener sexo conmigo Tenía que
estar disponible cuando él lo pidiera
tenía que cumplir sus fantasías sexuales
paras interpuso tres denuncias contra
este hombre identificado por la policía
pero no se hizo ningún seguimiento al
caso según ella las autoridades no
valoran a las personas transgénero
Va soportando las dificultades porque
cambia de sexo y de la transición y me
cuido si lo hubiera sabido antes me
habría suicidado
a lo que nos enfrentamos las cosas y las
caras de la sociedad y de los hombres
que vemos No creo que los chicos y las
chicas puedan verlo
desde 2018 Pakistán tiene una de las
leyes más progresistas del mundo para
las personas transgénero prohíbe
cualquier tipo de discriminación contra
las llamadas guayas
sin embargo siguen siendo marginadas a
menudo se ven obligadas a mendigado a
prostituirse para sobrevivir Hola
algunos partidos políticos religiosos
incluso ponen en entredicho la
existencia de la ley de personas
transgénero Este es el caso de llamad e
islamí que exige que la ley sea revisada
solo nos oponemos a aquellos aspectos de
la ley que van religiosamente en contra
de nuestra Constitución
Lamentablemente en Pakistán Hay personas
que quieren utilizar esta ley para
corromper la sociedad y la cultura de
nuestro país
esas personas solo lo hacen para
satisfacer a occidente
en karachi al igual que en el resto del
país la comunidad transgénero se está
movilizando
una de sus voces es
awan licenciada en medicina consultora
de desarrollo actualmente desempleada
soy médica pero fui excluida del entorno
hospitalario soy especialista en
desarrollo me excluyeron de las agencias
de desarrollo soy académica me
excluyeron de las universidades échenla
sáquenla y veamos si sobrevive nunca
había vivido esto es mi nueva realidad
desde mi transición antes no me había
pasado
de su vida cotidiana a luchar por los
derechos de las personas transgénero
como ella
Cómo están
en esta asociación como voluntaria con
personas transgénero marginadas y
Víctimas de la transfobia
alcanzamos Nuestro objetivo de realizar
pruebas de VIH a las personas que se
registraron como transgénero
recientemente
incluso fuimos a varios nuevos distritos
donde registramos a nuevas personas
transgénero
el problema actual es que tenemos muchos
transgéneros a los que solo les hemos
hecho la prueba una vez y creo que es
importante en vez de registrar a nuevos
miembros volver a hacerle la prueba a
los antiguos hemos visto un mayor número
de casos seropositivos cuando dice el
seguimiento tres transgéneros que habían
dado negativo antes dieron positivo Esta
vez y mis colegas tuvieron cuatro casos
positivos de los 13 que siguieron es un
número enorme Durante los próximos
cuatro meses nuestra estrategia debería
consistir en volver a hacerles la prueba
a todas las personas transgénero que
solo se la hayan hecho una vez en los
últimos tres meses
Porque algunos señalan básicamente es
que las caballas irá son malas personas
que son trabajadoras sexuales que
mendigan que no tienen nada bueno en sus
vidas y ahí es cuando alzamos nuestra
voz y decimos que es debido a la
marginación no es que la transfobia en
Pakistán haya aumentado Es que la
transfobia en Pakistán sea realzado
celebrado legitimado y se ha convertido
literalmente en una forma de ser
aceptado por el resto de la sociedad
culpa al discurso religioso
fundamentalista que ha ganado fuerza en
el país y a la minimización de los
delitos transfóbicos al menos 18
personas transgénero fueron asesinadas
en Pakistán el año pasado la tasa más
alta de asesinatos transfóbicos de Asia
a pesar de que el país cuenta con una
ley para proteger a los guayas irá